a looming government shutdown is
sharpening the debate over immigration
and daca program a CBS News poll out
this morning shows most Americans would
let young immigrants brought to the US
illegally as children stay in the US the
White House chief of staff says the
president that President Trump's
immigration views have quote evolved and
his campaign promises to crack down were
quote uninformed Nancy Cordes is on
Capitol Hill where the house will vote
on a plan to keep the government running
without daca without a daca deal Nancy
good morning good morning and what we
are watching now John is whether
Democrats make good on their threat to
vote against government funding set to
run out tomorrow night if there is no
daca deal and in a candid moment the
Senate's top Republican told me he's
trying to work something out but that
the president's lack of clarity isn't
helping daca divisions are consuming
Congress even as leaders insists they
all want the same thing we want to fix
daca we very much want to get a deal
done on daca we're all committed to
getting - yes small bipartisan groups
have already gotten to yes in the House
and Senate to me is a layup you have a
reasonable doctor solution with some
border security but the president
rejected one of those plans calling it
horrible
so congressional leaders are starting
over how is your agreement likely to be
different from the deal that was already
struck by a bipartisan group of senators
I'm looking for something that President
Trump supports as soon as we figure out
what he is for then I would be convinced
that we were not just spinning our
wheels it appears that he wants 18
billion dollars in border wall funding
plus an end to the diversity visa
program in exchange for giving legal
status to daca recipients what they want
in return is continuously a moving
target and it continuously expands
Democrats told White House chief of
staff John Kelly in a closed-door
meeting that's unrealistic campaign to
governing at two different things we
will
Kelly told them the president's campaign
pledges about a border wall were not
fully informed he's a very definitely
changed his attitude towards the dr.
issue and even the wall with funding set
to run out tomorrow night
Kelly expressed optimism in a GOP bill
that would keep the government open for
a few more weeks as I understand it they
have the votes and they're fairly
confident some have wondered how the
president would react to his own chief
of staff describing his campaign views
as uninformed well this morning we have
our answer bright and early the
president tweeted the wall is the wall
it has never changed or evolved from the
first day I conceived of it Nora the
president and his chief of staff appear
to be at odds Nancy Cordes thank you so
much